[Music]
foreign
you know there was a time where like
training for sports and training for
baseball really took uh what was was of
the utmost importance to me that started
to shift when I found this other thing
but it was also it was very clear to me
I was not good enough like baseball is
one of those crazy Sports where you can
be at one level you can be the best
player in the league and then you tick
up a little bit and all of a sudden you
don't belong right and and so the death
was like like I did not see a path yeah
once I started playing in these sort of
like Elite College sort of like summer
leagues whatever those like I was just
like oh man y'all are doing a game that
I can't really do did you have that or
would I would imagine be more
frustrating if you're like yo I can do
this dude left-handed pitcher I threw
hard and I can hit [__] home runs I
knew if I could put the right thing
together I had a chance at the show even
if it was just the miners I had I could
get paid as a baseball I've competed
with dudes that are in the show right
and I felt really good about dude I can
track a ball I can dive catch I could I
had all the tools wow but I wasn't
mature you know what I'm saying I made a
lot of dumb choices I was at Valley
Community College I got kicked out for
some stupid [__] what did you get kicked
out for
bro this is a [__] up [__] weird
story dude that's all good man so back
then there was a pager shop paid your
cell phone shop you have no kids [__]
pagers dude dude I know right before one
of our games I usually get a chicken
burrito was a [__] you know the
stupid [__] of a picture I had to have
the same meal every time same [__] yeah
I didn't wash my underwear yeah there's
a long list of weird [__] I did you know
what I mean still have rashes pretty
good
um me and a couple friends man we went
to into the pager shop just to kind of
see what's going on in there and I
farted dog I just farted like I thought
it was funny right you know I mean just
kid [__] teenager 18 year old dude and
the owner got so pissed bro he jumped
over the [__] counter and chased us
out and we're like oh [__] we run out
the dude's [__] trying to open the
door rip us out spit in my face [__]
try to put my homie out [__] we end
up getting out of there and [__] they
they try to press charges right
pressures for what farted assault or
some [__] right it was a weird thing
right we end up telling the story like
look here's what happened and imagine me
telling the cop like okay well it all
started when I farted dude
weirdest [__] awkward [__] bro yeah
it's just weird and so then the next day
in in practice the coaches is this dude
well I wasn't a fan of either way yeah
you know he said you know you're a
cancer go run laps pretty much blames it
on me I was like yeah okay I did do the
fart but like I didn't have this dude
chase me and [__] pull us out of the car
and try and [__] fight us we were
trying to fight the dude he wouldn't let
us out of the car and then when he tried
to I couldn't get the seat belt it was a
mess right yeah so then he made me run
laps bro and I'm running laps every flap
he was saying [__] like degrading that
[__] like you're a [__] cancer you're
a piece of [__] like really [__] like
and my father bro he kept coming to my
head bro my dad is a [__] G I've
never seen the dude afraid of [__] yeah
my father's the type of dude I [__]
never felt I was man enough because I
always felt fear of a fight I don't
think he ever feared a fight yeah and so
he was in my head he's like don't ever
take [__] from nobody don't ever take
let someone talk [__] you know and so
like my third [__] lap he said some
[__] I said no [__] you you fat piece of
[__] [__] shut up boom broke us up
you're [__] done I was like all right
well [__] it drove right away dude this
time it was a weird time in my life dog
I was one of those [__] like trying
to figure out at a lip piercing ear
piercing tongue piercing nipples pierced
long [__] hair half bleeps like a
[__] looks like Goku and [__] right
and I'm like going through a weird phase
right I'm trying to figure me out you
know so I showed the Glendale Community
College and the coach's like you sure
you played baseball and I was like oh
[__] I think I'm a left-handed pitcher
and I only said that because I knew it
was my way in right I can hit I love
playing Outfield but like I needed that
opportunity you know so I'm a
left-handed pitcher I throw pretty hard
and I got a good curveball yeah he's
like so I threw a bullpen he goes all
right you're on the team he goes any
other thing I need to know I said no man
I just want to play ball
flatulence probably besides that yeah
yeah so that's what got me out of that
college and into Glenn Community College
which was a blessing man we had a very
good season we're we are the Hall of
Fame team of Glendale Community College
we went to the Junior College World
Series wow
um I got to pitch dude I [__] my dad's
lacd firefighter right so the crazy
story is
I passed the [__] written test at 18
years old I have an oral interview the
same weekend as a [__] Junior College
World Series the coach goes listen
there's a good chance you're probably
not going to go pro because the fact
that the odds are [__] tough but you
can be a [__] Pro you can't be an Lac
firefighter he goes I would recommend
you go to that interview and I'm like uh
no I'm good I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
pitch in a [__] you know in the
championship game yeah yeah yeah my
dad's the same because Vinnie you know
we don't know what we're basically gonna
go but my friends are all on the board
you've studied this you got this so I'm
like no I'm gonna go play baseball like
why would you [__] come on stop that
yeah I'm gonna go play it yeah so I go
out there there's [__] tons of Scouts
I have a couple good Innings everything
is good we end up losing in the
championship game [__] double
elimination we lost twice to Riverside
[__] Community College studs I mean
they had like nine dudes are drafted
that year got it great experience
beautiful got to play with Fernando
Valenzuela Junior wow which was like bro
that you know he's an icon to any L.A
Latino you know what I mean for sure and
so it was a good time man but um I ended
up getting myself into some other
[__] and had a crazy relationship
that I [__] had to run away from dude
so I went up North played ball up there
to uh Chico's to Chico State area
there's a team called Chico sticks it
was a summer team a [__] killed at a
pitched well I hit [__] several home
runs full ride to Kentucky uh Nai
College in Kentucky called brush
University
so right now I'm like all right I'm
[__] up a little bit I was getting
looked at at Valley College there was a
couple Scouts that talked me out there
every game they're like hey you know
Vargas keep it up you're looking good
let's try and get that velocity up
you're right there yeah I'm there bro
left-handed picture I can say I could
throw a [__] curveball for a strike
like a [__] yeah I have pitching
coaches that used to pitch be a pitching
coach for Barry Zito for John Garland
for big names so I have the pedigree I
just had a [__] fine tune a few
things sure uh but then once I got in
trouble with that coach they [__]
stopped looking like I become like this
knucklehead right so I went to Glendale
I was only getting a chance to be a
secondhand closer and a middle reliever
and I just feel like I wasn't getting
the opportunities that I wanted but at
the same time I didn't deserve them
these guys have been on the team already
you know so I'm I'm trying to find my
way and then the personal life I'm still
partying like a dumbass I'm still
getting in trouble with dumb [__] I got
a girl pregnant right and and that
relationship was like
I mean if I had to say it was just an
unhealthy one as a kid and so I [__]
was like look I gotta get away for a
little bit I gotta try and hold on to
this [__] dream of playing baseball
so let me create some space from La
let's go up north I was headed to
[__] Oregon because I had a friend
there and I was like look I'll play in
Oregon for a little bit figure that out
stopped in Chico to party with my homies
and I ended up staying there for the
summer and playing on a team that they
got it for me so I was like it worked
out I woke up we [__] go swimming in
this [__] Lake out there uh in Chico
State and then I go straight to the
baseball game and bro I guess a free of
all drama I [__] killed it dude I
pitched like a [__] I hit
[__] crazy amount of home runs I was
calling [__] like I'm in a home run
today dog being gone you know what I
mean so they send tape to his team in in
Russian got me that full ride
I called my dad's like pop I got a full
ride dude like to Kentucky he's like are
you gonna do I was like abso [__]
lutely and you know what about the baby
I was like well she's like one month
right now two months and she's still in
the bay you know whatever wherever that
goes we'll figure that out but I can't
turn down a shot man I still got a
chance right I get down to Kentucky man
the first day I'm there I'm out of
Applebee's and
bro like there's just so much going on
I'm like I'm a kid that wanted to be a
dad but then got a girl pregnant at a
young age that I wasn't ready for and
I'm still trying to hold on to this
dream so so much is coming down on me
bro and now I'm alone in Kentucky dog
like there's like six of us that got
that broadened from LA and I'm not
really close to anyone and so I go to
this Applebee's by myself
and I'm India they had these tall boys
man and I drank one boom drank another
halfway ordered another one and I don't
know why I got so drunk and I'm just
yelling at the bartender I'm like [__]
you [__] you [__] you [__] you you know
what I mean like harmonizing in this
[__] he gets pissed as [__]
comes around the bar tried to fight me I
shove him boo boom they call the cops
put me in the back [__] seat and he
goes you're that kid from La I'm like
yeah he goes what bar do you want to go
to next I'm like oh [__] um whatever you
telling me you said that the cop bro he
played baseball brush University he read
the article about me coming to town it's
one [__] Street town so everybody
knows who's [__] playing on the team
wow took me to this park this bar called
Martin's this is the oldest liquor
license in Owensboro Kentucky and I was
like [__] yeah there's my new home you
know what I mean and that started the
path of like continuing this cycle of
like oh I could do anything I [__]
want I can just [__] fight someone
and they're just gonna pick me up and
take me to another spot
um I wasn't that lucky man like within
man within six months I had a great
preseason I'm [__] diving catches
home runs everything is going good
pitching very well
um I really felt like I was getting
things on track and then I became
academic academically ineligible bro I
failed Ceramics class dog that's the
[__] got me bro like making pots you
know I mean bro I failed Africa bro bro
look I was dyslexic and I didn't realize
that until I got into the military I
just dyslexia I shouldn't have anything
into a Ceramics no no well yeah no no
all the other classes didn't do so hot
so I was banking on this one yeah
it was like this midday class that was
like I'm tired [__] this you know me and
I'd fall asleep whatever the case and I
didn't drop it in time and so that put
my my GPA to 1.9 and I lost my full ride
man and I'm sitting in you know you know
I did I did theater in my college before
in Glendale right and I that's my first
taste of like oh this is kind of cool
but baseball dog basically you know what
I'm saying so now I'm in Kentucky lost
my full ride I don't have the heart to
call my dad and say I [__] up again
you know what I mean because it's
starting to pile up with these like
bro you know I got I [__] up again you
know and and I love my dad I think he's
a he's a tough dude
um and I never felt that I've
given him something to be too proud of
you know I mean I've wanted that like
proud of you son and I feel like for
many years it's always been like oh dude
you're [__] up you know what I mean
and you knew that that's what you wanted
back then no like looking back you can
see that but back then you think
it's tough when I made the choice to
join the military it was like you're
gonna fulfill several things with one
choice
I don't care about my life anymore
because I lost baseball
and so
as a father I'll give her money at the
time when you die in combat you get 400
000 I'm like cool she got 400 000 at
that time I thought that was a lot of
money and I was like cool she'll be able
to survive off this forever I don't
[__] know
um and I thought that she would be proud
of her father
because
I had nothing to be proud of myself
personally right I failed at the one
dream I had
um and then my parents would be proud of
me dude you know what I'm saying and and
I I watched this this interview on CNN
where this Marine put a American flag
over the statue's head and pulls it down
and they have the family in studio and
they're talking they're like oh we're so
proud and they're crying and like
sitting there in the bar and I'm like
damn bro I don't think I've ever given
my family anything that they can say
that same thing you know now I'm in
Kentucky I [__] up another dream
another opportunity
um and I just felt like I was at the end
of my rope of like
what the [__] am I doing bro you know
what I mean and um so it was like well
one choice kind of fulfills a lot of
things and that's me dying but it's okay
right like they'll be proud I'm a good I
serve my country for my country I serve
my country I die for my country my
daughter has money she could always say
her follow is a war hero whatever right
like I don't know how that was the
thought of me it was just like that was
it so let's go so I went the next day
the recruiter and as we're figuring out
which branch I wanted to serve in it was
the Army I'd end up choosing and I said
Special Operations yes Army ranger
please
[__] it let's go house soon six months
so in six months I knew I was going I
got two credit cards uh two thousand
dollars each and I [__] Max those
[__] out with partying and drinking
because I'm like [__] it here we go I'm
not gonna have to pay that bill I'll get
killed over there didn't really
understand it right didn't understand
how much time it would take didn't
understand anything
and uh join the military and when I got
into October 17th I got in uh and I
think it was by I went through all the
training of basic training went to
Airborne went to rip which is Ranger uh
Ranger induction program which is now
called rasp and that's our selection
right that's just your three week four
week selection of getting your [__]
dick put in the dirt until you [__]
don't quit you know what I'm saying
um learned a lot about myself then and
uh and then and then within getting to
Second range Battalion I deployed within
I think it was like 45 to 50 days of
getting there wow and it was like here
we go
man so
lots of digest I mean but but I mean
yeah I guess the first question I want
to ask you is that
so it's clear for you
your purpose or your your your your
um your drive for getting in like your
whole idea of getting in yeah
was basically to die yeah I mean like
that that's the way there was I died
already lost baseball right but right
and and do you think that that's common
do you think that's common that a lot of
guys sign up and they say I think
there's something like that right
there's a Tipping Point that's like [__]
it you know what I mean dude to join as
an infantry dude during war when you
know it's combat you're gonna go see
combat
it takes a very particular person right
it's like I could have joined and said I
want to be a cook I could I could have
join and said I want to do anything
other than the Infantry right there's a
particular person I believe they have a
chip on their shoulder there's some
reason where it's like
[__] it yeah right that [__] it button
whatever that is that was mine
[Music]
foreign foreign